[Music
] almost one hundred percent of the whole
body is black, even
the internal organs are black like
bones, everything is black.
My name is wirakusuma. I raise chicken
cemani in Indonesia
.
I was amazed I was
surprised because since childhood we have known that
there is a Chicken. The black chicken exists but
we have never met. Well, it was only
when I grew up that I was given three,
we started
to turn black on the chicken. Only this is because melanin, the pigment melanin, the pigment that made him go to Slank, made the
chicken.  The color and excess of melanin in
the cemani chicken makes them
very black. The
price of the cemani chicken varies
depending on the quality. Now
the price is around 10-20 million, which is
good money that
brings profits and brings
peace and
prosperity to the owner.
because we are  There was a
thick mystique in this chicken,
hi
hahaha but indeed we have
a chemistry relationship, yes, the relationship
between the mind and the chicken when we are
stressed and sick again It's not good The mind
is sometimes the chicken is also stressed,
doesn't want to eat if we are
happy, his father is also happy for him  I
want to raise cemani chicken, there is one thing that
I am proud of and for me as an
Indonesian citizen, this is a great honor,
so I will continue to
focus on chicken cemani
[Music]